S
ARTE
TICCH
CQ
OW
ALLOWED SOMEONE ALREADY CHARGED
WITH BAIL JUMPING, BAIL ON
$1000.
EVEN WHEN THE JUDGE KNEW OFHE
CRIME HE LED FOR 22 YEARS
VICTIMIZING OTHERS WHILE HE WAS
LOWED TO GO FREE AND LIVE LI
LIFE.
THIS CAN NO LONGER BE TOLERATED.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE CRIMINALS
OR WHY HE OR SHE DOES WHAT THEY
DO, I ONLY CARE ABOUT THE VICTIM
AND YOU BETTER START CARING, TO
BECAUSE SOONER OR LATER YOU, A
MEMBER OF YOUR FAMILY, SOMEONE
YOU CARE ABO, SOMEONE YOU KNOW
WILL HAVE THEIR LIVES DISRUPTED,
TORN APART OR DESTROYED BY A
DIRT BAG WE KNEW WAS A DANGER
BUT THE LEFTISTS DIDN'T WANT TO
PROSECUTE.
DO YOU HAVE THE WILL AND COURAGE
TO PURSUE JUSTICE ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS IN AMERICA?
BECOME A VICTIM IS IGNORED OR
CRIME GOES UNPUNISHED OR
VIOLENCE IS EXCUSED UNDER
PROGRESSIVE LEFTIST PEOPLE AND
BY AMERICAN, O SOCIETY ERODES
FURTHER, IT BECOMES HARDER,
MEANER AND MORE VIOLENT.
NO ONE WANTS TO BELIEVE HIS
NERVES AND MURDERERS ROAM FREELY
IN OUR MIDST, THEY'VE COMMITTED
ALL THE TIME OF PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD BE IN JAIL BUT MAKE NO
MISTAKE, THE PATH WE ARE ON
RIGHT NOW UNLESS WE STOP IT
LEADING TO THE DTRUCTION NOT
ONLY OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT AMERICA IS THE LAND
OF THE FREE AND THE LAND OF
JUSTIC